face à la première
[Musique]
bonjour chers aux auditrices et
auditeurs y compris sur notre site
internet pour ce face à la première
effectivement avec deux sociologues
invités juliette sméralda et moïse du
dino présentait aussi donc par jean-marc
parti qui vous interrogera madame et
monsieur bonjour juliette sméralda merci
d'avoir accepté cette invitation et
bonjour moïse oudinot merci à vous aussi
d'être là bonjour jean marc partie oui
moi je moi je
nos invités bravo jean marc partie
rédacteur en chef en martinique première
où va la martinique lignes de force
traverse son corps social
quelles sont ses espoirs et ses peurs
voilà quelques questions auxquelles nous
allons tenter de répondre avec vous
d'abord on va vous demander à chacun de
nous dire rapidement nous rappeler quels
sont vos domaines de prédilection dans
votre travail dans votre activité
professionnelle nous commençons par
juliette sméralda merci alors pour la
question c'est vrai c'est très important
de faire remarquer qu' on n'est pas
social dans l'absolu on a donc des
domaines d'intervention de recherche et
donc je me suis spécialisé on a bien sûr
une approche générale de la sociologie
mais ça suffit pas pour devenir un
spécial et du tout donc je me suis
spécialisé dans la culture dans tout ce
qui attrait notre histoire parce que un
bon sociologue est un bon historien
d'abord et dans tout ce qui fait oui
parce que si on connaît pas l'histoire
on est dans la main de grosses
difficultés à appréhender les
comportements donc tout ce qui fait que
nous sommes des martiniquais même dans
l'informel m'intéresse et donc je je
travaille
j'écris quand je peux je fais des
petites biographies des petites mines
aux monographies qui apportent des
connaissances dans ces domaines voilà
with you
alors moi je travaille davantage dans
les rapports sociaux ordinaire
en principe et en particulier sur la
question de l'identité l'identité
antillaise est relancée français être
franc c'est tout simplement comment la
constitution comment au travers de
l'histoire
on est devenu français voilà c'est plus
tout ce qui m'intéressait plus les
rapports sociaux ordinaire alors juste
pour préciser pour nos auditrices la
sociologie des sciences sociales qui lui
d'analyser et d'interpréter les faits
sociaux les phénomènes sociaux dont neuf
à des mouvements d'action collective du
syndicalisme à la politique en passant
par les faits les plus individuel ou en
tout cas ce qu'on s'unisse visuel mais
en réalité qui peuvent être reliés à des
comportements collectifs
donc l'idée bon vous madame et monsieur
défi c'est de décrypter un peu le nôtre
réel et donc c'est dans ce cadre que
nous avons demandé aujourd'hui de venir
discuter non pas de la séquence
politique que nous vivons en termes de
sociologie électorale qui peut qui est
également une spécialité de la
sociologie mais qui n'est pas la vôtre
on l'a bien compris mais en tout cas à
partir de ce que nous vivons là depuis
quelques mois avec l'élection
présidentielle qui est finie aujourd'hui
solennellement avec l'investiture du
nouveau président d'une part et d'autre
part avec les élections législatives qui
arrive il se ferait se fait un jour des
revendications des deux mondes des
interrogations un esprit de curiosité
civique est en quelque sorte pour
commencer d'émission comment avez vous
vécu toute cette séquence là en tant que
citoyen en tant que chercheur pour ma
part avec
alors d'abord je la première chose c'est
que je n'ai pas de télévision chez moi
donc je n'ai pas été sous les feux des
médias est sage et très peu lu ses
soutiens surprenant pensée soul of the
boys avoir de oui c'est vrai que mes
mais parce que ce soit on peut
s'informer évidemment autrement qu'avec
la télévision heureusement tout
simplement parce que j'estime que la
télévision bon c'est vrai que c'est un
média qui est important média de masse
qui est important mais le problème c'est
que je trouve que il ya quelque chose
d'un peu manipulatoire dans la
télévision la presse la radio et puis
surtout les informations de terrain
parce que je suis davantage dans la
clinique
donc je suis obligé d'être ancré dans le
pays je suis obligé d'être ancré dans
les rapports sociaux ordinaire ici de me
faire tout petit même si je me suis
remarquer non pas parce que je me fais
remarquer les patrons me reconnaît et
hélas un rapport d information comment
j'ai vécu ça j'ai vécu sec de l'
angoisse
alors attendez juste vous allez nous
expliquer mais donc le citoyen français
que vous êtes n'a pas regardé ce matin
devant son poste de télévision
la passation de pouvoir entre françois
hollande et manuel mon compte pas le
moins du monde
pas le moins du monde je n'ai même pas
lu les programmes de monsieur macro le
programme le schéma cronie le programme
de madame le pen du tour mais j'en ai
entendu une partie mais j'ai passé
moi j'ai surtout vécu de l'intérieur des
choses alors vous disais la séquence
avec avec beaucoup d'angoissé parce que
c'est la première fois de ma vie que au
premier tour je vais voter je vais vous
donc de l'angoissent la première fois sa
voix oui je suis allé voter il ya quinze
jours avec beaucoup d'angoissé
j'ai voté avec beaucoup d'angoissé parce
que ce que j'entendais au niveau de la
martinique c'est que j'ai entendu
beaucoup de martin qui nous dira jamais
fauté le pen et ça je me suis interrogé
je me suis battu avec lui pas battu mais
je suis j'ai échangé avec eux et pour
essayer de comprendre ce qui pouvait se
passer et parfois essayé de les emmener
vers une autre pensée mais je crois que
les gens sont tellement en colère
tellement
agacé tellement au bout de tout que au
final on pourrait citer une solution
mais je ne passerai sur la suspension
jeudi à smara d'arrêt parce que moi j'ai
pas alors cette séquence qui j'ai enfin
j'entends bien l'idée qu'on puisse est
angoissé c'est vrai parce que il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'incohérences dans ce
qui se fait actuellement et on a
l'impression que tous ceux qui faisaient
le tissu social qui faisait le lien qui
faisait du sens qui donnait de la valeur
à ceux qui sautent décision qui a été
prise tout cela s'est effrité envolé et
que au dit tout et son contraire dans la
mesure où on nous a demandé on a permis
à marine le pen d'arriver aux élections
on nous demande en fin de compte de ne
pas voter pour un jeu tel que ya un raté
dans la démocratie auquel il faut
réfléchir
et puis quand elle est sur le point
effectivement maddin de bénéficier
j'allais dire de des retombées de la
démocratie avec tout ce que cela à de
dangereux eh bien on nous demande de
barrer la route à une personne qu'après
son élection on demande déjà où on nous
demandera à l'ue a lui aussi de barrer
la route
donc on est donc une sorte de
décomposition de la démocratie et de ce
qu'ils faisaient que ce que nous
faisions avait du sens dans cette perte
de soi parce qu'on est deux à mon avis
ce su ce qui m'a dit m'a le plus
interpellé il ya une semaine une perte
du soin mais nos élites peut-être pas
seulement au lard de retomber sur leurs
pieds qui est absolument bluffant parce
que parce que on se dit alors j'ai
entendu beaucoup de gens guerre connaît
on ne peut pas dire qu mais pardon on
est à la radio ce film et ça se dit pas
mais c'était le questionnement et pour
un sociologue qui a étudié à proposer
des explications qu'est ce qu'on dit aux
gens allaient voter pour macro et vous
aurez bien le temps de lui tomber dessus
c'est à dire que tous les désordres
sociaux qui sont là nos prévisions tous
ces désordres la la république les les
autorise et après on verra peut-être dix
crs ou si on a encore dit et c'est pour
rétablir l'ordre
voilà en quelque sorte de confusion un
peu quand il ya une confusion des genres
mais là on dirait que la république a
perdu son sens de l'orientation qui ne
sait plus très bien où elle va même si
on a fait justement pour l'intronisation
peut-être on va mettre des guillemets de
monsieur la constitution non non je dis
et redis diversité et bien on a vu tout
ce protocole est loin qui est
impressionnant qui fait frissonner qui
fait monter les larmes aux yeux de je ne
sais plus qui a dit que les larmes me
sont venues enfin c'est quelque chose
d'assez superficielle qui nous fait
perdre de vue l'essentiel
mais ce sont nos élites qui nous font
perdre de vue l'essentiel est donc ce
moment là où va-t-on donc moi ces
élections je l'étais je les ai trouvés
scandaleuse j'ai trouvé que nous étions
scandaleux j'ai trouvé que l'état était
scandaleux et je ne comprends pas où va
donc j'attends de voir comment ça évolue
il préside hilawi et donc on m'a par bon
ce que je regrette profondément résumé
eu l'occasion déjà de lui dire je lui ai
déjà dit
je ne vois pas quel est l'homme
politique martiniquais puisque nous
parlons de la martinique capable de
porter un projet martinique où est ce
que je veux dire c'est à dire que tout
le monde est dans ces petites choses
dans ses petits souliers
on a l'impression que c'est du push
moins d'accord c'est à dire que c'est
seulement quand on priait avant 10
heures priez pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
prier pour moi
selon là le vieux du tondu avait tout le
mal qu'ils pensent au bond et donc on a
pas on à paris il n'y a pas d'homme
politique je le regrette profondément
d'hommes politiques suffisamment lester
permis tant le bain de donner au peuple
une direction permettant de d'aller vers
quelque chose c'est juste des luttes
était un personnel pour du pouvoir pour
moi est que beaucoup de communication on
est beaucoup dans beaucoup de démesure
va la cosmétique beaucoup de
communication et on sait pas finalement
le projet d'ailleurs c'était vrai pour
macro jusqu'à la fin on s'est demandé
quel était le projet de maquereaux alors
justement juliette sméralda est-ce que
y'a pas un paradoxe aussi dans ce vote
qui a eu lieu là pour cette élection
2010 est à la fois on l'a vu beaucoup de
colère de désespoir qui s'est exprimé
effectivement en partie par le vote pour
le front national
c'est l'explication coréen pas que ça il
n'ya pas n'y a pas que ça on dit il n'ya
pas que ça mais c'est peut-être aussi un
moyen d'exprimer ce sentiment parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre voie l'autre
voie voilà donc cette colère et puis cet
espoir qu'on veut nous vendre entre
guillemets avec cette élection est élevé
le président
récemment élu le dit lui-même qu'est ce
qu'il a dit là dans son discours
d'investiture les français ont choisi le
7 mai l'espoir et l'esprit de conquête
je le cite à jean le site et vous allez
réagir il ajoute depuis des décennies la
france doute d'elle-même dans la france
et tous les territoires français
d'accord on peut y incluant bien sûr les
martiniquais l'a7 france se sent menacée
dans sa culture dans son modèle social
dans ses croyances profondes
elle doute de ce qu'il a fait voilà
pourquoi sous mon mandat sera guidée par
deux exigences rendre français cette
confiance en eux depuis trop longtemps
affaibli et voilà donc la première des
mois j'ai envie de dire pour répondre à
ça directement depuis 1789 et je remonte
à très loin
la mutation sociale qui a eu lieu n'a
pas permis le rapprochement entre deux
peuples
les anciens esclaves et des anciens
mettre d'accord on n'a pas constitué une
nation permettant de parler de diversité
on a bossé sur des chimères quand on
parle de diversité quand on parle de la
france avec cette diversité etc sont des
chimères
nous sommes sur une r1 et identitaire
nous sommes sur un lien à cette identité
aquitain qui nous qui produit d un effet
nocebo c'est à dire le placebo ces jeux
plairait le lot c'est beau c'est julie
rey donc un effet indésirable de mauvais
médicament donc nous sommes sur ça par
ailleurs nous avons du mal nous mêmes à
nous constituer en tant que nation pour
une raison qui est simple que tout le
monde ait pas sociologue et en plus très
peu de gens connaissent l'histoire de la
martinique et pour pouvoir garder de
notre ancrage pour pouvoir parler de qui
nous sommes
nous devons avoir des dates 1789 1848 ce
sera plus aussi du code de l'indigénat
ce que ça veut dire se rappeler du
bumidom ce que ça veut dire qu'elle
était et c'est qu'ils sont des choses
constituante et de l'identité de la
construction identitaire martiniquaise
parce que vous savez bien que il
une tendance ici qui dit qu'on va on est
toujours tourné vers le passé assez by
ancien teint hâlé bouffant qui a fait
jouer mais c'est marie voix mais c'est
même cette réticence de la wii mais
simplement parce qu'elle est cette
mission manqué peut-être de l'école
d'abord c'est volontaire ou involontaire
et volonté à cette mission accomplie
quand vous quand de madame taubira dans
les années 2000 fait voter la loi du 10
mai qui n'est pas la loi c'est la loi du
10 mai c'est une loi permettant de
reconnaître les esclavages comme crime
contre l'humanité et permettant de dix
ans par ailleurs que cette histoire doit
être apprises à l'école pour permettre
aux enfants dieu de france et de navarre
de comprendre les soi-disant 10 en or
nous sommes loin de ce marché et puis on
parle de nous sans jamais nous impliquer
vous voyez comme vous regarder les
reportages en télé nous sommes le seul
peuple qui n'a pas de représentant
officiel qui parle de son histoire
c'est toujours sur toujours les autres
notamment de l'état au nom du peuple
moi je voulais c'est une priorité
politique d'esprit de conquête
parce que voilà ce soit cet espoir est
inscrit tout est est ce que nos moi j'ai
été brutalisé par cette idée là je me
suis revu au xvième siècle quand on
partait sur des sur des navires ou des
bateaux de je ne sais plus aménagé pour
aller à la conquête du territoire et ce
monsieur qui est un jeune homme m'a
beaucoup surpris parce que ses aînés
avaient eu l'air d'oublier ça lui qu'ils
ont géré le patrimoine colonial quand
même hein ils ont géré l'afrique est
aujourd'hui plus que jamais ils disent
que l'afrique leur appartient ils disent
d'ailleurs très textuellement l'afrique
est l'avenir de l'afrique est l'avenir
de là où la france
enfin son avenir c'est l'afrique
d'accord et monsieur zhu qu'il
responsable de dieu
du j'ai pas du mémorial de la fondation
de la présentation pendant du mahdi a
dit si on peut le voir encore sur
youtube que l'afrique appartient à
l'europe
d'accord donc cette histoire de conquête
me dis qu encore une fois la france va
chercher sa grandeur à l'extérieur je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas si c'est une
conquête du territoire qui est déjà
conquis aussi ce soit d'autres
territoires parce que la conquête à
infini c'est l'afrique a terminé c'est
l'afrique
donc j'ai envie de j'ai été très
sincèrement très très étonné d'entendre
cela de la bouche d'un président alors
maintenant il faut rassurer tous ceux
qui ont un peu la nostalgie de grandes
puissances mais pour revenir à ce que
dit monsieur oudinot on ne peut pas
faire payer parce qu'on n'a pas de
bourgeoisie nationale parce qu'on n'a
rien fait pour cela contrairement aux
pays d'amérique de l'américano phone on
n'a rien fait pour ça donc on n'a pas de
bourgeoisie nationale et aujourd'hui
vous êtes dans ce qu'on appelle une
société plus rails c'est à dire une
société coloniale qui ne peut pas tenir
c'est une promesse de diversité ou
d'universalité en donnant à chacun la
garant de l'assurance que eddy à sa
place vous êtes dans une lutte à la
martinique qui est absolument et toi
d'entre les groupes et ça c'est une
chose qu'on nous cache
mais rien ne peut se dire où se fera la
martinique si chacun des groupes ne
surveille l'autre et l'autre on essaye
de dos on est dans la capacité
aujourd'hui pourtant de faire une juste
une définition bon choisi nationale
c'est un terme qu'on n'entend que c'est
vrai parce que
disons la discours marxistes attendant
ça sinon disparaître en tout cas du
public bien que le reste l'a alors
expliqué notant que bourgeoisie
nationale et vous dites que par rapport
aux pays et aux colonies hispanophone
idem aux anciennes colonies nam qui se
sont beaucoup des cubes à porto rico en
jogging on vous dit que nous n'avons pas
ça qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que ça
voudrait dire aujourd'hui en 2010 cette
bourgeoisie nationale en martinique ça
veut dire que pour diriger un pays comme
le nôtre qui dans une grande discipline
et dans une concurrence entre les
groupes il aurait fallu une autorité
comme au venezuela comment à saint
domingue comme à cuba et c'est qu'ils
soient locales
c'est à dire peu importe sa couleur de
peau mais c'est une autorité locale qui
s'est séparé de la métropole chez nous
nos colonnes ne se sont pas séparés de
leur métropole et la bourgeoisie mulâtre
kipushi était en on va dire en justes
noces à la cité nous oui elle est aimée
elle avait déjà clairement elle était en
capacité d'assumer ce rôle mais il ya
les guerres qu'ils avaient mais vraiment
je sais pas si on peut les appeler
fratricide entre composantes mais là des
composantes b qui n'ont pas permis
justement que ces deux composants qui
était au niveau de la formation du
statut et cetera
franchement en mesure d'assumer un
destin martiniquais ne l'ont pas fait et
des tentatives content il ya que ce soit
à paris c'est ce que je vous dis on a on
a vraiment cassé les reins be set et il
a fini en dans une prison bon donc on
n'est jamais allé au plus loin que des
embryons de etc
cela nous jeunes joueurs à un tour qui
quitteraient très néfaste dans si vous
voulez difficile à rattraper par rapport
à un projet de société qu'on aurait un
projet de société qui ne peut pas se
réaliser
parce que notre société qui très jeune
n'a pas ne s'est pas stabilisé
les groupes les relations entre les
groupes ne sont pas stabilisés et ce
qu'on appelle la diversité en fait c'est
une sorte je vais être un petit peu
brute une sorte de turcs en blanc qui ne
tient
que parce que c'est la france qui nous
gèrent de 8000 km à l'est où avec ses
représentants qui soit mais que moi ici
vous ça qui dit que c'est une chimère
que ça ça n'existe pas mais on n'a pas
mesuré le set par prise tout de même par
les électeurs de martinique j'ai envie
de dire parce qu'il n'ya pas que des
martiniquais qui votent en martinique
cette part prise par les électeurs de
martinique tout de même dans la victoire
emmanuel macron mais aussi ce qui a
précédé le vote massif au premier tour
en tout cas majorité au premier tour
pour le jean luc mélenchon et sa france
insoumise entre guillemets le la montée
des voix de marine le pen au premier
tour avec un doublement de son score 2e
tour
tout ça pris ensemble qu'est ce que cela
dit de notre société de son état
d'esprit actuel de ses préoccupations
selon vous ça veut dire que nous sommes
dans une société où l'identité devenu
pathogènes
ça veut dire que pathogènes dans le sens
malade nous sommes malades
identitairement on a une heure à ty anti
terre c'est à dire une fausse identité
nous sommes dans une situation où
les hommes politiques que je le répète
encore je lui dis encore s'il y avait
des hommes politiques capables de porter
un projet martinique capable de faire
l'unité au niveau 2 de la nation
martinique pas si on peut parler de la
sur martinez qui nappe qui n'existe pas
nous avons un problème identité a tout
simplement parce que nous sommes dans un
processus de socialisation qui s'appelle
la simulation que l'assimilation est un
processus où les deux jours dans salah
en 2007 une aiguille c'est une évidence
c'est une évidence l'assimilation c'est
un processus qui existe depuis très
depuis un an et 90 10 répond il est
encore à l'oeuvre selon mais il est une
évidence parce que le la dernière
boutures la dernière non tu de la
simulation c'est la dispersion la
disparition et la dispersion c'est quoi
la dispersion ses comptes
vous faites partie d'une communauté
parce que l'assimilation c'est quoi
c'est que les candidats à la simulation
c'est à dire non ou des personnes qui
viennent en france doivent avoir des
points leur permettant de ressembler à
la société
bon allons nous avons beau parler le
français m les et à ne plus manger les
airs nous avons beau manger avec des
fourchettes à gauche des cours d'eads et
des couteaux à droite
nous avons beau nous habiller de manière
aussi élégant dans du lait ou dans
d'autres soient répétées dans de la soie
je me permets de dire ça de cette
manière là il se trouve que la
dispersion qui est l'élément finale de
la simulation ci que nous ayons perdu 6
que le candidat à la simulation est
perdu toute notion de son identité pas
si oui alors fond dans le paysage à
quelqu'un sauf que en veulent être en
prison à danville est d'accord donc le
problème que nous avons c'est d'abord
que 1
malgré tout ce que nous pouvons faire
nous ne pouvons enlever sûr qu'on
appelle un stigmate comme al comme
dirait
kaufmann goffman dépanneur ou fanon est
ce stigmate que nous avons eu la peau
qui du coup nous nous renvoie à quelque
chose de différent sachons que depuis
plus d'un siècle
depuis mes 15 mois du siècle avec les
anthropologues moi qui me faisais ces
mecs-là je les aurai rencontre et je
peux vous assurez vous les auriez
malmené d'accord faisant bain mais tout
ce qu'ils ont décrit d'afrique comme
sauvage tous ceux qui tous ceux qui
disent que l'homme noir est un diesel et
ça donne je lui aurais bien botté les
fesses je vous assure volontairement je
verrai botter les fesses donc
verbalement ou physiquement et je trouve
que c'est grave et le problème que nous
avons c'est que comme on a mis dans la
tête des gens qu'il faut être blanc pour
pouvoir être français les gens se
blanchissent dans le comportement
les oublient leur culture il faut des
buts maison avec piscine dans lesquelles
une semaine qu'une fois tous les maisons
où ils payent des impôts tous les goûts
tous les mois quasiment les thiney les
machins comme ça nous pas qu'à manger ça
on 20 dont 10 face à l'invasion
on va au supermarché madame titres sont
4es de vente si la chine ça ne nous
intéresse pas à nous voulons manger des
frites de pommes de terre
vous comprenez donc c'est ça le problème
que nous avons à partir de moments quand
on nous dit que notre culture notre
musique notre danse notre team il n'est
pas valable sauf quand il est mort que
notre mona n'est pas valable sauf quand
il est mort et je pense que d'autres
1 voilà et donc si moi le problème je ne
veux pas accuser simplement la france
parce qu'il faut arrêter ce bordel
d'accord nous sommes respectés je pense
qu'il faut arrêter ce bordel je dis ça
j'dis avec limoux s'est cru je crois que
les gens savent où un petit ami qui s'y
tient aujourd'hui
non je pense que les hommes politiques
les bilans je finis en disant que encore
une fois mois les hommes politiques ici
j'ai envie de leur dire messieurs il
faut arrêter vos conneries
il faut arrêter vos bêtises et penser un
peu aux peuples et penser un peu non pas
à vous en tant qu'individu vous n'êtes
que des passerelles d'accord c'est vous
qui devait permettre quand on est élu
quand on donne à quelqu'un le mandat
c'est pour permettre de représenter le
peuple et le faire en sorte que le
peuple et satisfaction pour l'instant je
n'ai pas du tout ce sentiment là je ne
sais pas du tout comment ça va se passer
pour le mois prochain des élections
législatives qui vont arriver
je ne vois pas du tout qui va me
représenter sur la question de de
l'assimilation il ya un très beau livre
très beau livre de bertone qui est
enseigné sur le campus qui j'en ai
longtemps les chaînes bretonnes qui
s'appelle la famille coloniale est ce
que nous disons il me semble de
l'assimilation n'est pas tout à fait
historiquement fondé quand en 1789 on
dit la france décide donc qu'elle va
faire exister les citoyens quelque 20
des gens qui ont le doigt du vote
nous sommes maintenus en esclavage
la préoccupation de la fois c'est qu'est
ce qu'on va faire de ces gens là et à ce
moment là déjà en 1789 burton nous dit
que la décision de la simulation était
déjà avait déjà germé dans la tête
d'ailleurs c'était le projet de cours de
crise le chercheur c'est de ce n'est pas
né avec nos martiniquais ce que
j'observe mois dans la façon de regarder
les documents et le discours que nous
avons sur le terrain
la croyance que nous avons que nous
influence sur notre destinée
c'est viens de l'habileté qu'elle
colonisateurs ou là la france
aujourd'hui en tant qu état moderne de
nous faire croire que nous sommes ceux
là qui avoue pris ses décisions et c'est
pour cela que la simulation peut nous
écraser parce que ceux qui sont allés la
demande et ils ont bien vu quand ils
sont revenus sur leur décision qu'il
était trop tard et comment revenir parce
qu'au fond la vraie machine à assimiler
sont pas les gens même si on dit qu'on a
des responsabilités
la vraie machine a ainsi glissé la
france écoutez la france a elle est là
elle nous est aujourd'hui que le soleil
ne se couche pas ne se couchent nul pas
sur son oreille son empire
on est bien d'accord s'il fallait faire
un régime
à vos gammes scolaire qui tienne compte
de la réalité de chacun de ces deux
chacune de ces colonies ou ex colonies
s'il fallait faire une
un programme qui tienne compte de la
réalité du desiderata de chacun du fait
de ces deux chacune de ses possessions
mal la france serait encore à en écrire
voyez donc qu'est ce qu'elle a fait elle
a choisi d'appliquer de manière
absolument brutale parce que c'est
violent
l'assimilation c'est à dire un programme
pour tout le monde et ce programme c'est
celui des français c'est à dire ce sont
les français de france et il valait les
français en raison de 10 hockey quand on
est français on est blanc ils ont raison
ils sont dans quelque chose de logique
parce que la france ne leur a pas appris
qu'elle avait colonisé qu'elle avait
fait du mal et qu'elle avait donné le
doit à d'autres de s'appeler
français et ça c'est la faute à la
france d'augmenter reddition de l'aide
de la simulation
j'ai vraiment je remet vraiment en cause
en question cette manière que nous avons
de quoi que nous avons c'est comme pour
les articles là qu'on a voté
regardez les pressions que monsieur
sarkozy a fait sur la population après
les gens vont voter mais comme pour
macro on vous dit ce qu'il faut faire et
après on vous dit que vous avez fait des
choix
mais non il faut que à un niveau un
autre on se décide d'être de vrais
acteurs et qu'on dise
vous voulez qu'on fasse ça eh bien nous
nous ça n'est pas dans notre intérêt ce
qui nous ramène à la cmp au moins
politiques sinon politicienne et vous
dites moïsi du nom qu'il n'y a pas de
leader ou d'un mouvement politique
suffisamment panthéon d'avenir deux sens
c'est tout de même pas un peu exagéré
quand on sait que on a exagéré on dit
bien oui je vous pose la question il ya
18 mois nous avons une élection à
l'assemblée de martinique avec les
autres majorité de gens qui ont voté
pour sinon un projet en tout cas une
manière de faire de la politique une
vision de la martinique donc on peut pas
excuser que nous avons géré le leader ou
des lits des géantes et d'une dame dire
que c'est un joli louis delluc et je
partage cette idée alors j'ai envie de
vous dire deux choses d'abord ce que
l'assimilation est là que la question
ait plus aucun regret parce que je pense
qu'il faut abandonner un petit peu
l'idée de la france mais un marathon qui
est une marâtre mais il faut que nourrit
vignes alessandria et puis comme nous
fallait des caunois
d'abord quand on parle de la simulation
nous sommes pas en quoi on est dans ce
regard blanc parce que nous sommes dans
une démocratie représentative
ça veut dire que les personnes qui ont
qui lui représente les élus doivent
représenter le peuple et comme le peuple
majoritairement blancs et que on se fait
l'idée parce que quand même dans la
bible on nous a menti un jeu je veux
bien quoique samson et dalila était noir
je veux bien croire que jésus était loi
ils n'ont pas bleu et blanc avec des
yeux bleus
donc toutes ces questions là toute cette
machinerie intellectuelle toute cette
manière de mettre de la condition
sociale c'est à dire dont nous dans
dents
dans le disque dur en parler du monde
d'aujourd'hui dans le disque dur d d d
hommes martiniquais et des noix on aura
eu leur a enseigné il aura appris nos
ancêtres les gaulois et on a formé tout
ça le processus d'assimilation et de
processus jubilatoire il se veut
unitaire mais ils coupent toute l'étape
qui des basses mais nous la deuxième
chose non mais quand je vous dis c'est
pas cette fois ci à rome et attendait
mais on a une prise de conscience de
plus en plus importante de la population
qui s'est lui-même aujourd'hui la
dimanche par exemple il ya le village du
convoi pour la réparation qui montre
bien qu'il existe deux types de votre
réseau qu'un an et puis un modèle
proposé par la réparation c'est prévue
un peu plus tard à oui non pas comme
dans l'émission oui ah bon il est prévu
qu'on dit aujourd'hui on vous sent oui
parce que il ya quelque chose qui me
dérange par exemple quand monsieur
romana qui est un antilles est d'accord
que j'ai rencontré dans les années 90
moi j'étais à paris où j'ai lutté pour
des choses romana comité de fond du mal
à notre communauté
d'abord visuel romana quand elle parle
de la femme potomitan excusez moi au sco
ci afin potomitan c'est que la femme
potomitan son seul souhait c'est de se
marier quand même quand il va signer
avec toutes les personnes qui vous qui
avec qui il a signé la fédération
esclavage réparation je vous signale que
les initiales de ces promos donne fpr le
faire alors quand on sait quand on est à
ce niveau de compréhension quand on est
à ce niveau de connaissance quand on est
à ce niveau on doit s'interroger sur ça
mais je reviens je j'abandonne saab
revenez sur la question d'un cm dit oui
alors vous vous lancez météo ou deux de
nos élus en général nous avons 34 maire
nous avons
si par le maire qui nous emmène c'est
pour cela qu'on dit que c'est une
escroquerie parce qu'aujourd'hui le
réformisme ne peut pas face à la shoah
la dramaturgie sociale dans laquelle on
ice sociétal le réformisme ne peut pas
le trouve nous donner les solutions
qu'il faut il faut véritablement à le
prendre les problèmes à bras le corps et
essayer de proposer des ouvertures sur
la question de je veux bien que la
france ne soit pas la mer marrade que
qu'on veut sommes-nous laquelle mais
sans études mais je veux dire tout ce
que nous avons essayé sur le plan de
l'école j'ai entendu mais c'est ni leur
proposer des amendements pour l'école
pour faire c'est pour faire ça on lui a
dit nous on lui a dit non mais je pense
que nous croisons une trentaine de fois
c'est à dire que quand nous regardons
les plans sur lesquels nous sommes en
mesure d'agir
ils sont très maigres à mes avs juliette
et je l'étais smeralda mais une vision
des choses quand je crois qu'il y avait
73 74
moi je n'étais pas leurs mots de ce vote
je vivais à paris il ya tant de la
constitution pour genève ou
d'institutions nous avons bien avant
nous n'avons nous n'avons pas du tout
autre moi je crois aujourd'hui que la
société dans laquelle nous sommes
devraient permettre d'avoir une une
capacité de décider pour soi
d'accord sans être dans une parce que
quoi qu ait dans les dépendances est une
hérésie
on ne peut pas être dans une
indépendance parce que ma part qu'on va
combiner nous est fait pour vivre
puisque c'est la poutine est seulement
une vérité bien que ce soit nourrissant
donc aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire une
chose si que quand on a voté ce qu'on a
voté là quand les hommes politiques
oui moi moi moi j'ai entendu jantes alu
des grandes choses j'ai entendu de se
rassembler pour donner au pays une chose
jusqu'à maintenant j'attends j'attends
la première marche de la chance on va
pas non
mais ce que je veux dire ce que je veux
dire titech quitte à être polémique je
je je dis aujourd'hui ils ont pris vous
savez moi dans la rue j'en vois des gens
qui marchent
d'accord je travaille avec des gens
j'accompagne des gens d'accord
j'accompagne des gens qui ont fait des
bêtises
j'accompagne des gens qui ont violé
j'accompagne déjà qu ont frappé mais
j'accompagne aussi des gens qui sont
petits morceaux dans la société
d'accord je vois des mecs qui sortent de
prison quand vous êtes à fort de france
comme moi je me balade à fort de france
et que je vois des jeunes de 20 ans de
25 ans qui violent le comportement de
mecs qui sont en prison et qu'il
reproduise à l'extérieur ce qui laisse à
ceux qui viennent derrière ce n'est que
cet exemple quand vous avez des hommes
politiques qui ne sont pas capables
encore une fois je le dis il ya des gens
qui sont en train de souffrir il ya des
gens qui sont en train de mourir il ya
des gens qui sont malheureux
on est une société qui est de 10 selon
iker impérial
ces personnes politiques qui sont là
sont loin
même moi vous savez pas ce que j'ai
l'air un peu particulier même des
personnes politiques que je vois on me
regarde avec un petit air de nenê n'est
pas la vocation était de savoir est ce
que nous avons un personnel politique
nous avons un système qui ont dit que
nos élus manche à côté du peuple et non
pas mais ils couvrent et ne connais bien
du peuple
non mais je veux pas citer de noms
mémoire et justement il vend du peuple
mais c'est cela qui est très étonnant
c'est que ils sont une fois qu'ils sont
au pouvoir dans la société à laquelle
nous sommes
qui est vraiment quand même structuré
autour du népotisme et des réseaux et
des clans et d'une surveillance très
étroite de qui prend le pouvoir et qui a
le droit de parler de parler
ces gens là sont sous contrôle une fois
que ces gens-là accède au pouvoir ils
sont au service en général de la classe
moyenne ou de la bourgeoisie et ils sont
entre eux au quotidien
il faut que c'est un autre quand ils
vont à l'assemblée nationale quand yvon
le peuple n'est pas là il ne le voit pas
qui plus est ils ne le connaissent pas
combien de martinique et connaissent
leur histoire c'est ce on a commencé
l'émission par ça
combien de martinique et connaisseurs
histoire quand vous parlez aux élus vous
voyez qu'ils sont très peu à être
documenter suffisamment et la vie
politique à la française qu'on leur
impose leur demande des 24 heures sur 24
le nez fourré dans des dans des dossiers
qui sont écrits par là
heures qui pensent d'ailleurs et qui
leur demandaient des complices et d'un
cliquez ici ce qui a été décidé a eu
mille kilomètres donc ces gens là ont
perdu leurs peuples de vue en général on
va pas exagérer il ya quand même
quelques personnes qui font attention
mais ils n'ont pas les moyens ou ces
personnes n'ont pas les moyens d'influer
sur la situation de pauvreté alors on
peut revenir sur le choix de le pen on
dit si on n'avait d'autre choix par
exemple pourquoi ils n'ont pas voté je
sais pas moi poutou on ne peut pas voter
poteau d'aucuns quelque chose dans le
disco de le pen qui est plus musclée qui
fait que le peuple que nous sommes qui
est issue d'une plantation ou le la le
rapport était très violent il aime
entendre les discours carabine et il
aime ça
d'ailleurs quand on vous dit vous n'avez
pas obéi quand on vous dit comment on
tape son enfant comment il faut faire ça
ça écoute et les coups de gueule vous
sentez que c'est une culture que nous
avons qui nous vient de la socialisation
que nous avons subi le pen et carabines
et dans ce sens soit elle peut faire
plaisir mais les gens ignorent les faux
nous en du mouvement lepénistes et c'est
pour cela que dans la forme de la forme
de deux d'imposition culturel que la
france nous impose que nous vivons à
travers la simulation nous vivons
beaucoup de choses que les gens ignorent
de les gens ignorent l'origine et ne
savent pas véritablement fait un joli
kiosque appelé le fond les origines du
du parti du front national
vous dites que les gens ignorent alors
que l'on sait d'où il vient ben moi je
vous dis qu en compte tenu du fait que
quand nous parlons il ya très peu de
gens qui connaissent leur histoire et
qu'il ça n'intéresse pas vous même vous
avez dit tout à l'heure
les gens vous disent moins en est fini
puissant nous aller de la fin alors
audit parce que quand on ne sait pas
quand on est aveugle cantona sur les
yeux bandeau noir mais qu'on est mû par
une sorte de voile à de pulsions qui
vous pousse vers l'avant qui d'ailleurs
un discours idéologique qui arrange tous
ceux qui ne veulent pas qu'on parle de
réparation et tous ceux qui ne veulent
pas qu'on entende dire qu'il ya des
problèmes parce que ça gêne l'économie
je n'accepterai et c'est donc tout ça
fait que excusez moi je finis ça j'aime
le fait que les gens quand je dis que
beaucoup de gens ignorent l'origine les
origines du mouvement le pénis ils ne
sont peut-être même pas intéressés à
connaître c'est changer parce que ce qui
fait dans la société de consommation
dans laquelle nous sommes
nous ne consommons pas seulement des
biens devenus des biens de consommation
courants nous consommons a aussi des
idées des postures des exercices
jean-luc des biens symboliques voilà
tout à fait donc sa série poursuit parce
que les 50 minutes d'émission passe très
vite l'everest à peine un quart d'heure
pas tout à fait moi je dis non les mots
la sémantique sas a aussi son importance
dans cette affaire dans la
représentation qu'on peut avoir par
rapport à ça et on a l'impression que
justement là encore il ya un paradoxe
parce que dans les mots voit par exemple
que vous parliez de mer marâtre en
parlant de la france mais fut un temps
on en parlait comme de la mère patrie
mans nantes en plus ça tellement on est
plus à utiliser le terme la métropole on
préfère peut-être de manière il y en a
qui l'utilisent encore mais de moins en
moins il y en a qui ont moins de dix ans
c'est rien et des élections on parle de
l'hexagone de je ne sais quoi on ne sait
pas d'ailleurs des fois pas me rationner
désigné la france métropolitaine donc
voilà alors tout ça qu'est-ce que ça ça
dit aussi parce qu'en fait on a
l'impression que les rapports changent
alors on entend parler aussi d'autonomie
peut-être mais maintenant on entend dire
pour apprendre du 74 pour le mettre dans
le 73 bon est ce que tout ça c'est un
peu de la poudre aux yeux
finalement pour masquer cette
assimilation qui est toujours à l'oeuvre
vous disiez tout à l'heure j'ai
l'impression changent les mots jeudi que
certains debout je ne dirais pas que
c'est de la poudre aux yeux jeudi
l'accès de la poudre de perlimpinpin
vous suivez comme vous avez entendu ce
matin mais le bien évidemment je suis
quand même ancré dans la société lgd
j'ai des portes d'entrée qui sont
multiples et variées donc de la biètre
de perlimpinpin oui c'est de la poudre
de perlimpinpin qu'il a une autre bêtise
quand même
bon donc ce que je veux dire c'est que
un an on devrait d'abord se poser la
question de qui sommes nous où allons
nous et que devons nous faire
qui quoi quand que - avec qui ainsi la
base d'un projet pour toutes les
personnes qui mènent des projets quel
que soit un projet mashaie on va où avec
qui comment quand et c'est la base de la
construction du journalisme aussi du
reportage journal aussi bon le vrai
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est que
notre identité n'est et l'identité
j'écris un livre qui s'appelle corps
noir est républicaine le paradoxe
antillais dans ce livre je traite du
sentiment d'infériorité et de ce qu'on
appelle la reconnaissance négative
la reconnaissance négative est une
blessure morale il s'agit de montrer à
quelqu'un la blessure morale c'est de
faire en sorte que kaka souffre que ce
soit de manière directe ou indirecte en
lui disant quelque chose que cette
personne nous reconnaissent la
l'infériorisation qui est fait mais nous
même dans notre culture nous mêmes dans
notre manière de faire n'avons pas la
possibilité plus nous impliquions vous
voyez même dans les rapports suspects
ordinaires
nous sommes dans le delluc de classe
nous parle d'une lettre d'un nom du du
duduk et du schabel bon mais tout ça
c'est le même tableau on est tous là
même tonneau simplement les gens on est
dans une société qui se dit aujourd'hui
qu'il faudrait qu'on arrête d'être dans
la représentation est dans le paraître
est ce que font veut prendre des vessies
pour des lanternes et qu'on voulait dire
par là c'est ce que je veux ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'elle peut relever
on devrait on devrait avoir une vision
méliorative de notre société c'est à
dire pouvoir parler de ce que nous avons
fait là la reconnaissance négative c'est
la dépréciation c'est à dire sentiment
d'infériorité de le contexte culturel de
la reconnaissance dans lequel l'individu
doit se reconnaître systématiquement
dans ce qu'on doit dire et 3 qui le plus
important l'absence d'une communauté
réelle est idéal de référence ça veut
dire quoi a lancé alain caillé et
c'est nous qui nous aveugle ont aussi
quelque part mais bien évidemment
mission que fouquet nous agite le miroir
effectivement et les commissions
regarder ailleurs
peut-être tout simplement le discours
tout simplement pour arriver pour pour
arriver à sortir de ça il faut que l'on
dise ce que je lis et esmeralda et moi
sont montrés de dire il est important
qu'on attend de se mouiller ce discours
il est important que que ce savoir que
que je l'étais smeralda à soins soient
rendus publics
il est important que toutes les
personnes qui travaillent sur ces sujets
là disent la verroterie reich au
bayonnais c'est d'accord bébés non non
non c'est donc navale au mythique dont
[Rires]
on n'a pas un discours qu'il y ait non
plus bruce et qui n'ont plus ici je le
déteste mais ryan et moi il ya cinq ans
avait été on avait un discours qui est
brossé et donc il faut qu'on arrive à se
dire les choses sans violence alors on
peut avoir la brutalité dans les mots on
peut avoir de la bousculade dans les
verbes
mais l'essentiel c'est de constituer une
nation un peuple des gens pour que les
gens comprennent leur histoire et aiment
leur histoire moi je demande qu'elle
possession de la france a réussi à
s'émanciper de la france voilà donc moi
je crois que l'art de la france et de
son staff autour c'est de nous avoir
fait croire que nous étions les acteurs
comme pour la simulation et de nous dire
ce qu'on veut aux fêtes c'est
l'assimilation mais aux vins vous faire
porter le projet est comme ça il sera
vain et même notre grand césaire un
marché donc le projet de l'assimilation
n'est pas un homme n'a jamais été plus
je voulais vous dire qu'en plus le défi
de la société martiniquaise de sortir de
102 diffèrent de ceux de ce raisonnement
de ses deux revenus vont se construire
non moi je dirais se construit quand
l'autre qui est à l' qui vous qui vous
contrôler en permanence vous laisse une
marge de liberté et c'est cette marche
de liberté qu'il faut conquérir ce que
vous dites par exemple la loi taubira
c'est une loi qui est devenu mémorielle
alors qu au départ c'est une loin qui
permettait qu'on condamne ceux qui
commettent des des impairs contre contre
notre humanité et c'est aujourd'hui
c'est devenu une loi mémorielle
on a des substances ya lisez cette loi
sur la question de la décennie des
afrodescendants l'onu qui reconnaît les
relais les discriminations que nous
subissons nous peuples noirs ou
descendants reconnaît depuis durban en
2001 que le peuple noir est le peuple le
plus discriminé au monde
toute cette résolution la voix la
résolution adoptée par l'assemblée
générale le 18 novembre 2014 est fait
pour nous on demande aux nations au pays
donc à la france aussi de s'occuper de
son peuple de ces de ses anciens
colonisés et de leur donner des chances
de s'en sortir en vous êtes d'accord sur
ça mais je suis d'accord le problème
c'est que nous sommes dans la décennie
des personnes d'ascendance africaine
2014 2025
non seulement nos médias n'en parlent
pas mais nos politiques ne relaie pas et
ses poteaux une institution
internationale
absolument et l'état français comment
faut-il le portugais parce qu'il y en a
qui disent que c'est encore une posture
de victimisation mais continuer à
pratiquer on lutte contre les
discriminations c'est un devoir de la
démocratie un devoir de la république en
que fait la république en ayant
justement la mainmise sur tous ces
territoires extra hexagonal elle envoie
ses percées ccbc personnel qui occupent
des postes que les locaux auraient pu
occuper et ce sont eux donc encore une
fois qu'ils se servent de crohn et c'est
bien pour cela que l'onu nous dit est
dit à la france entre autres qu'il faut
protéger ses citoyens
anciennement colonisés et je sais pas si
c'est fini mais enfin voilà le propos
est là
donc il ya toute cette résolution qu'il
faut lire que nos élus devraient
médiatisé et que luca c'est bon ils sont
courants et que l'état français n'est
pas sûr que l'état français devait quand
on a eu l'année 2011 année des personnes
d'ascendance africaine la france l'a
transformé en année des outre-mer il ya
eu une autre année j'ai pas en quoi elle
l'a transformé
elle refuse de reconnaître qu'elle a
colonisé qu'elle a mise en esclavage
un peuple qui étaient à 95% à l'époque
africain est donc qu' un doigt à une
reconnaissance à un traitement mais mais
qu'on lui restitue son humanité on a dit
que le code noir n'est pas encore
abrogée on n'y pas dans l'avs de la
fantaisie intellectuelle donc il y a
dans notre population une misère qui est
lié justement à cette absence de
reconnaissance de son humanité
une misère mais à tous les niveaux que
il me semble que le peuple ignore et de
ce fait là on a beaucoup de difficultés
a dit aux gens mais nous sommes pas tout
à fait des êtres humains aux yeux des
français et qui va permettre qui va
permettre que ces problématiques pour
soit porté sur la place publique et
soient traitées pour que enfin de
soignants apaisé alors à aller avec lui
moi j'ai envie de dire qu'à un moment
donné il faut casser le moule
d'accord il faut qu'on sorte de
l'émotion pour raisonner le problème
c'est que nous sommes beaucoup sur
l'émotion nous sommes un peuple
d'émotion moi je dis encore une fois
gardons nos émotions
mais il faut parfois en sortir pour
raisonner d'accord on dit alors j'ai
attendu longtemps que l'homme blanc
était l'homme de la raison que l'homme
noir était le peuple de l'émotion mais
j'ai envie de dire mais je les sens et
hélène tout comme les mots et moi j'ai
envie de dire ce qu'elle a envie de dire
qu'importe la raison moi je veux garder
mes émotions parce que ce qui nous fait
pleurer quand on vient au monde si nous
émotions et puis les gens recommencent à
travailler mais ce qui me met en contact
avec le monde ce sont nos émotions
donc ça c'est une chose on parle du code
noir mais le code noir il faut
rajouter au codm a le code de
l'indigénat qui est la base de la
colonisation et les gens ne connaissent
pas ça quel homme politique
les hommes politiques qui sont là et ce
en vue de faire quoi de se faire élire
ils n'ont pas envie de se faire
forcément mal voire d'une autre côté
quand ils vont à l'assemblée nationale
j'aimerais bien les entend tenir des
discours permettant de donner quelque
chose
j'aimerais bien que les hommes
politiques qu'ils viennent aujourd'hui
demander mandat pour être député
la série the oc sont accolés à temps ce
film je finis le film je finis en disons
que j'aimerais bien que ces hommes
politiques et un disco permettant de
valoriser une bonne fois pour toute
notre martinique il faut arrêter de
penser que l'on joue haut et on est dans
un creux d'écart entre deux rives la
martinique et la métropole
ici on joue au gros coco et puis là-bas
on jouera la soubrette d'accord donc il
faut arrêter
non c'est pas le système ce sont des
zones non c'est non
ce sont des hommes de la même manière
que nous sommes scientifique les hommes
veulent pas rompre complètement avec le
système c'est peut-être pouvez-vous
rejoindre là dessus s'est dit ouvert
depuis les hommes qui sont qui ce samedi
certaines ont des lois sociales
sérieusement soyons sérieux
ça manque de force ça manque de courage
c'était en mai l'association
oui mais oui oh oui je suis d'accord
c'est parce que vous voyez monsieur
macro qui est élu la cie à des hommes
politiques capables de porter quelque
chose de porter quelque chose je pense
que ça peut être entendu le problème
c'est que comme l'histoire c'est pour ma
gueule c'est ça ce n'est plus prier pour
nous mais priez pour moi est le problème
si ce que ça pose quand on aura des
hommes politiques et je finis à 10 ans 1
lorsqu'on aura des hommes politiques
capables de faire la synthèse de ce dont
nous avons besoin de prendre en compte
la réalité sociale les souffrances
qu'ont les gens et qu'en plus on va
essayer de faire en sorte qu'on évite de
banio le martiniquais pour mettre métro
à la place parce que c'est une réalité
qu'on va essayer de donner aux
martiniquais la force qu'il a rejoint la
revendication de
réparation en question est ce que c'est
un des défis par exemple que que la
marque la société martiniquaise peut se
donner à faire aboutir de réussir cette
affaire de préparation à halle au moins
la question de la réparation ça me gêne
parce que derrière derrière il ya la
question de l'argent certaine résilience
de mickey ou des entrées d'argent
pourrait passer par là aussi
oui mais déjà pour être beau être dans
la résilience il faut qu'on soit
conscient de ce que nous avons vécu et
que nous ayons des éléments d'abord ce
que nous devons faire c'est éduquer les
gens à mieux comprendre leur société à
mieux connaître la société de manière à
ce que lorsque l'on part dc econova
ailleurs comme moi je n'ai vécu on dit
qu'on parle pas de soi mais ce sont des
exemples d'accord je ne vais pas prendre
l'exemple de deux titres ceux que je ne
connais pas mais quand je suis allé en
grèce et qu'on m'a demandé qui j'étais
j'ai dit que j'étais français
on m'a dit est ce qu'il ya des noirs
français j'ai expliqué l'histoire et
c'est là que j'ai pris conscience de
l'importance de mon histoire donc
connaissons notre histoire
faisons en sorte d'avoir un socle commun
permettant de défendre des choses
défendons notre culture
et arrêtons de penser que un coq qui
dans une maison gêne que les bateaux les
canaux qui ceux qui partent à 4h30 du
matin empêchant de dormir et
sélectionnez centre a empêché les
français qui viennent s'installer ici et
qui ceci bien ce que je dis aux
territoires matin les français parce que
toutes les institutions et temps restent
durs en territoire conquis même temps
qu'eux mêmes et toutes les instituts de
moi je suis le plan sociologique je
parle en termes d'institutions nous
n'avons pas eu de rupture depuis l'
esclavage avec les institutions
françaises qui sont en place et tous les
français qui arrivent aujourd'hui gentil
à zéro heure une minute à 0 1 2 minutes
ils ont changé parce que ici le système
colonial est en place et les gens le
voient toutes les institutions en place
tous les fonctionnements sont franco
français donc l'initiative mach il ya
quelque chose
l'histoire avec eux qu'on nous avait des
mères quand vous avez par exemple
le feu le fait que sur le plan
institutionnel nous n'avons pas eu de
rupture fait que lorsque nos hommes
politiques s'il y en a qui osent
s'opposer à ceux qui sont en france
et bien ces hommes là sont punis il ne
faut pas négliger
vous avez au marin un préfet qui a
défendu des petits jeunes je crois sur
un terrain etc
qu'est ce qu'ils étaient qu'est ce qu'il
est advenu de ce monsieur ce préfet non
seulement il a été renvoyé et ne pourra
plus jamais être préfet et même sous
préfet il a été casés dans quelque chose
qui ressemble à une direction de deux
d'une institution d'un organisme mais
voilà comment les gens sont punis et
quand ils ont travaillé qu'ils ont
l'impression que ils ont mérité cette
récompense parce que l'accès au pouvoir
dans nos colonies ou en tout cas dans
notre société qui sont encore dans les
dépendances un peu coloniaux l'accès au
pouvoir c'est une récompense de
compromission de beaucoup de choses à
partir de là ces gens là quand ils font
ils ne vont pas dans le sens du pouvoir
sont punis et il faut qu'on tienne
compte de ça pour ne pas considérer
qu'ils sont délibérément dans quelque
chose d' affreuse mans anti peuple aux
antilles et il y a quelque chose à quoi
réfléchir eux mêmes est-ce qu'ils ont
décidé d'être des pantins est ce qu'ils
continuent à jouer uniquement sur le
terrain de la france où est ce qu'il
propose à la france quand il le faut
vous avez vu ce que ça donne pas ce que
j'ai entendu nulle or pour l'école mais
on n'a rien eu donc chaque essai des
réparations elle est au coeur de d'une
évolution qui nous permettraient de re
réhabitée notre humanité et surtout de
faire que les antillais les lego
guyanais et martiniquais est du pays
connaissent leur histoire était en vie
de cette histoire et qu'il ne continue
pas à dire qu'ils n'ont rien à voir avec
l'afrique
merci judex merad dame merci moïse
oudinot à vous entendre on voit que la
martinique encore
duchemin elle va mal et elle a encore du
chemin à faire pour donc au moins se
responsabiliser et pour d'autres
s'émanciper selon ce que l'on pense en
tout cas merci merci d'avoir participé à
cette émission d'avoir gagné déjà à nos
questions et nous qualifier beyrède
merci merci à jean marc partie merci
merci à vous bon appétit dans quelques
instants
le journal qui vous sera présentée par
laurie anne virassamy mavs antirhume
elle sans vous donnera des nouvelles du
temps on dimanche
face à la première
[Musique]